mm and dates The Strangers was a simple
story of a random home invasion that
resonated with audiences worldwide while
its box office performance warranted a
sequel no one thought it would take
nearly 10 years to happen but now the
strangers have returns and though they
might be in a new setting with a new
cast the threat the invaders present
remains the same the strangers pray at
night follows a family of four parents
Cindy and Mike their son Luke and a
daughter Kinzie when they set off to
visit relatives in a countryside trailer
park their vacation turns to Tara when a
trio of masked invaders descends on the
family with murder on their minds now
that we're all safer home let's break
down the ending of the strangers pray at
night spoilers ahead the pool is closed
the climax of the movie kicks into high
gear once the parents are out of the
picture as Kinzie and Luke set off to
flee the trailer park but after a nasty
encounter with Dollface Luke tells
Kinzie to lay in hiding while he sprints
for help alone he doesn't get very far
when he makes it to the trailer parks
Paul he comes face to face with the axe
wielding man in the mask Luke puts up a
struggle taking the fight into the water
but his overpowered cuts up and left to
drown it seems like things are over
until two hands burst into the water and
pull him up its Kinzie
back on her feet there to save her
brother in the nick of time with his
wounds much more severe than hers the
siblings switched places
as Luke hides away while Kinzie makes a
break for it stumbling into the street
to a passing police officer who shows up
so out of nowhere that Kinzie can barely
believe her eyes as Kinzie falls into
the arms of the officer
neither of them notices a killer
Dollface approaching from behind by the
time that Kinzie sees her it's too late
to do anything but watch the officer get
murdered one shot one kill in one of the
movie's most harrowing moments Kinzie
tries to commandeer the police car while
Dahl fate overpowers her pushing her
into the passenger seat as she stabs at
her over and over and just when you
think it's all over Akin's he gets
tactical where is she a police car and
this one has a shotgun the movies most
hopeless scene pivots to his most
triumphant moment as Kinzie crubs her
shotgun and executed all fate with one
brutal blast of the head
I think were alone now after surviving
another scrape a Kinzie tries to start
at the police car while a truck pulls up
alongside Kinzie it's the man in the
mask of course both stranger's movies
are notable for showcasing the playful
sadism of the killers often they get a
chance to execute their victims and just
don't preferring to terrify and torn
their prey there's no reason why that's
what's so horrible about it they found
people that are awake and they thought
that that would be a fun thing to do is
to torment them in the sequel it's a
tactic that works against them allowing
their victims just enough chances to get
lucky get away or get revenge this time
the man in the mask stones of choice
involves cranking the volume on
Tiffany's I think we're alone now it's
an on the nose choice the music is great
because I mean you're screaming your cry
and then you have beautiful music that
like my mom grew up and that used to be
happy and pool parties and like summer
vacations playing over it twisted metal
the man in the mask backs up and smashes
into Kinzie's car until both vehicles
explode into flames
here the ultimate stranger begins to
appear to be unkillable surviving the
explosion to chase down Kinzie and his
flaming truck while she flees on foot by
then the fire has burned off the man's
mask but it's also burned away the flesh
of his face with the killer remaining
anonymous right down to the bone this
moment as well as an earlier instance
where Kinzie declines an opportunity to
remove doll faces masks is sort of the
whole point of both films the monster
movies that don't have any monsters in
them the killers aren't Freddy Krueger
they're just people and they could be
anybody
in the original The Killers removed
their masks off-camera making the point
that their true identities don't matter
that's what makes them all so scary if
you survived an encounter like this how
could you ever trust a stranger again
the thing that I love is that I don't
know who the strangers are and I think
they have absolutely no reason to do it
that's what's scary the hitch-hiker
Kinzie sticks to the roads that she runs
pursued on foot by the man in the mask
as a pickup truck approaches just as you
think the encounter is only going to up
the killer's body count luck turns
Kinsey's way again she leaps into the
back of the truck screaming as a burns
of Axman crabs and swings at her the
truck builds up speed the killer loses
his grip and Kinzie escapes the ending
is highly reminiscent of the conclusion
of the Texas Chainsaw Massacre and just
as open ended
[Music]
Vall Texas Chainsaw cuts the credits at
that point the strangers pray at night
continues and that's when things get
ambiguous the bittersweet end the movie
ends on the reveal that Kinsey's escape
led to Lutz rescue with the newly
orphaned siblings reunited and the live
in a dark hospital room save for the
machines the room is silent until
there's a knock at the door Kinzie
doesn't panic but she's paralyzed
someone's outside the door a stranger
but is it really a killer the truth
doesn't really matter the ending is a
metaphor for trauma and the lasting
effects that a horrifying experience can
have on a person's psyche what did her
family do to deserve this torment
nothing and nothing they could have done
would have prevented it
go to your home the fate of her family
was tied to the whims of three strangers
and the least one of them could still be
out there that knock at the door is
probably a nurse a doctor a family
friend but after this experience no
matter what's Kinzie can never put her
trust in the kindness of strangers again
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love tea
[Music]